con los periodistas excluidos de la
corte estas son las únicas imágenes del
juicio contra aung san suu si ahora que
ha sido sentenciada sus abogados no
podrán reaccionar ya que una orden de
silencio no les permite comentar
públicamente
inicialmente fue condenada a cuatro años
pero tras el perdón parcial de la junta
la sentencia quedó de dos años por
violar las restricciones de kobe e
incitar contra el ejército
amnistía internacional condenó
inmediatamente el fallo las duras
sentencias dictadas contra aun sang soo
choo por estos cargos falsos son el
último ejemplo de la determinación de
los militares de eliminar toda la
oposición y sofocar las libertades en
mianmar es el primer veredicto de una
docena de cargos que también incluyen
corrupción violación de secretos de
estado e importación y uso ilegal de
walkie talkies la sentencia máxima
combinada significaría más de un siglo
tras las rejas sus partidarios dicen que
los casos son infundados y diseñados por
los militares para poner fin a su
carrera política
el partido de un samsung chip había
ganado de manera aplastante en las
elecciones generales del año pasado pero
fue arrestada y su gobierno derrocado
por los militares el primero de febrero
en las semanas siguientes las protestas
convocaron a cientos de miles de
personas que se han encontrado con una
represión mortal amnistía internacional
dice que el ejército ha matado a 1300
personas desde febrero y ha arrestado a
miles más la junta ha defendido sus
acciones contra aquellos a los que llama
terroristas